2023 is just a few days away and we here
at Channel 8 news are putting the final
touches on our spectacular New Year's
Eve show Good Day Las Vegas anchor John
langler spoke with the hosts Nikki Novak
and Michael Yo ahead of the big night
it's almost time to ring in the New Year
and once again Las Vegas has the biggest
the bestest the baddest New Year's Eve
party in the entire world 8 news now is
going to ring in the new year with a Big
Show from coast to coast from The Palms
Hotel Resort right here in town the
casino and once again hosting our big
program you can see them on your screen
they're already dancing it's comedian
and actor Michael Yo and TV personality
Nikki Novak welcome guys welcome back to
Las Vegas how's it going
what's up how are you so excited we're
excited we're excited too so let's talk
about the big program this year what can
people expect
they can expect wins number one
well that's the thing with live TV you
never know what's gonna happen right
we're gonna be three plus hours live on
the air what they can expect is we're
gonna kick off the show in Times Square
with the fireworks display there at
midnight and then we're gonna count down
three more midnights across the country
ending of course here in the best place
and you guys know you're Vegas we have
the best fireworks show in the country
shooting off all of the you know top of
the resorts and it's just going to be a
huge party we can't wait that's right
yeah we can't wait for it either looking
forward to it hopefully the wind and the
rain steer clear though but we're
talking about a big long program aside
from the fireworks shows this is a big
show there's a lot of big performances a
lot of big acts a lot of big
entertainers as well
yes the ax will blow you away
we have Casey Donahue a phenomenal
country artist we have Belinda uh
Carlisle will be on the show and also
Motley Crue they're my favorite yeah
such a thing Michael's going to put on
his tight white pants his sailor hat and
he's gonna dance for you guys all night
long he's probably gonna end up in the
pool I will I will end up in the pool
this is just a party spot because look
we all live in Vegas we know it goes
down here better than anywhere else in
the country so we're excited to be apart
tune in for the tight white pants but
stay for the Motley Crew I guess is the
lesson of the day so this the big
National broadcast here guys how can
people who are watching at home get
involved
okay you don't have to ask Michael twice
what did they you want to be involved
well let me show you gotta so so Mikey
Minden a huge choreographer to the Stars
I mean he's designed the Pussycat Dolls
Oscars he did our opening dance and I
was in it and I had background dances
behind me and we did this dance that you
can do online right now all you got to
do is go to your station's website and
learn to dance with me and then we will
put you on the show it's just that
simple so we do a little this right here
you know all right we're looking forward
to seeing how that plays out once again
our live show begins at nine from the
Palms Resort Casino we'll be on until 12
30 New Year's Day showing you all the
fireworks from coast to coast and of
course lots of live entertainment and
music for you